hello and welcome to this video a new
Blitz game haven't gotten around to do
much videos lately my d4 project is
really taking up all my time and I still
of course teach but less than before but
still very busy with all the projects um
difficult to really maintain daily
videos it's um really a kids off you can
only do one thing at a time in a way
it's really too much to do everything at
the same time okay now sorry we got him
should I have paid attention to Bishop
d2
got an Evans gambit here line where I
returned the pawn and white didn't mind
taking it
yeah I have to be careful queen h5 looks
like an attractive move but 95 is a good
reply to that
I mean more than good so queen h5 it's
not good because of 95 so going Jim
simply complete my development here
maybe after he went Bishop b2 I could
have thought about Queen to g5 actually
I think this is something that I should
have considered
the queen is really well placed on g5
threatening Bishop takes h3 now he might
have d5
No ok so let's take this opportunity
so he's planning to play
yeah it's plan to play Knight f3 against
my capture on h3
why exactly been doing that
but f4 as well now it's got f4
you
and this is useful opening the e-file
getting the bishop on a good diagonal
maybe Scott d5 planned that definitely
um is an idea
No
yeah that makes sense though
still on c5 maybe undermining
undermining the night okay so if I take
what is he doing then Queen takes
come on maybe
you
you
hmm young so difficult not to take
actually
don't want to alarm to play d5
[Music]
yeah but if I take quintics
what what did I do wrong there
you
you
I already thought I had a good position
but I don't
I absolutely don't have a good position
whom
I don't know
what did I do wrong to noon not happy
with this move but I couldn't quite see
what what I should do
or D 5 is good for white
which is kind of obvious like he doesn't
do a tournament
maybe this is good film as well not sure
the d5 was an easy advantage
dynamic maybe
Knight f5 something that
this may be possible
for
maybe g-force it's a thing
G for where do I go
for 9f5 stuff
have a tactic Wow really
still a snide f5 okay
Kinski
tempo
didn't me maybe
- here making
preparing this I mean making whatever
making it I came
now I've got this nicely under control
the ship f3 was debatable but its pawn
structure is a complete rank now and
that is definitely worth something and
that is a rogue baby okay oh it was what
was difficult I don't know something I
did wrong I think roughly I mean I
honestly think that this line is just
not good anyway like this is good for
black I mean I've got the Bishop f4 for
nothing basically but I mean good good
what black I mean I have no problem at
all and I'm quite happy to play like I'm
not saying a bit of it it's as rather
harmless okay so an important point
don't do this there's ninety five does
this happen in a tournament game I have
I've seen a game yeah and you lose the
house here because this is an
intermediate check ok c6 is kind of
normal
that was odd and no no I'm better right
so the engine wants me to simply take on
h3
I was thinking f4 is a problem
ah okay I only saw that this is good for
what and I did not spot that I can just
go here
aha okay because of what exactly this
this is this check
and NYCHA for the
that is good I didn't zere yeah the
bishop t6 was a mistake we went here and
that is probably the next mistake now
white is fine no I played c5 f4 and the
engine wants me to capture on d4 I did
not do that because I thought you were
to take with the Queen I was very scared
Bishop c7 I was scared that some Knight
g4 is a problem but well it does not
really it doesn't kill me it just looks
so dangerous him and this is not an
immediate threat he's got c5 but the
engine thinks this is OK for me I'm
slightly worse on him yet be 65 I mean I
spotted that this is better for white
bird seed he didn't do it now white is
better yeah okay but he did not play
that and now I think my position should
be fine
I still expected to him no here Queen
Texas Bishop c5 so Bishop takes but
should be seven yeah and now we had g4
I mean actually that was lucky you know
I I can do this which I didn't see
before
this and this I spotted that but only
really laid that was not planned always
got rooked eggs
I only I only solved that but this is
actually not working I'm getting
checkmated in a nice fashion ouch okay
so what do i do again Sisseton
takes Knight takes I have to take anyone
with the Queen
that is crazy so and then check King g1
take and this and this is somehow okay
for me
threatening to take 1d for him No
what the what the heck
I got some materials of like I got
nothing but
Queen a3 is the best move it seems then
I'm supposed to take take here check
there is some kind of draw I don't know
that's crazy
very crazy okay that is not best yeah
quite clearly some take tick at the
bishop evade is not the best move Knight
h5 is stronger but okay I'm still having
a clear advantage he's got many problems
their structure is in ruins and tongue
camp the whole piece coordination is off
you know you don't have to take there
but it's a simple way to play right now
we'll never repair his pawn structure
obviously that didn't help it it was
very bad anyway he has a hard time to
move and all those pawns are quite weak
okay let's thanks a lot for watching